et nous sommes avec elle le crav vice
président du syndicat national des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels bonjour
et merci d'être avec nous a déçu bon
matin et hier le gouvernement a donc
promet notamment une revalorisation de 6
% de la prime de feu qui la fera passer
de 19 à 2 10% à 25% du salaire
c'est satisfaisant ou je crois que vous
demandiez 28% alors c'est satisfaisant
sur ce point là mais là l'augmentation
de la prime de feu est un des points que
nous demandions parmi un panel de
plusieurs dizaine de revendications dont
des revendications qui touchent à
l'organisation du service a la charge
que supporter sapeurs-pompiers des
revendications quant aux agressions des
questions qui se posent sur la retraite
donc hier nous discutions de la seule
augmentation de la prime de feu il était
demandé d'augmentation à 28% à l'instar
de ce qui se fait pour la police nous
obtenons 25% et nous considérons que
regard de ce mouvement qui a débuté
n'ont pas cet été mais déjà le 14 mars
puisque le 14 mars dernier nous
rencontrions monsieur castaner pour lui
présenter ses revendications
au regard de cela durait de ce conflit
nous nous considérons que ces 25% c'est
quelque chose qui est acceptable
et sur ce point là uniquement nous
prenons acte et nous sommes en phase
avec le ministre alors le gouvernement
s'est aussi engagé à préserver les
mécanismes qui permettent aux pompiers
de partir en retraite anticipé à 57 ans
en échange de cotisation supplémentaire
sur ce point quelle est votre réaction
alors le mécanisme a toujours été de
cotiser pour ces années supplémentaires
ils ne sont pas gratuites simplement la
possibilité de conserver ses deux pas de
pouvoir partir cinq ans plus tôt est
conservé dans le nouveau dispositif et
la question du financement reste sur la
table sera a priori assurée par une
cotisation des employeurs et là sur ce
point nous sommes aussi satisfaits de
pouvoir conserver ce départ en retraite
un peu anticipée parce qu'effectivement
à 60 62 64 ans être opérationnel porté
secours jour nuit sur les incendies et
du secours d'urgence à personne c'est
compliqué et le gouvernement devrait
aussi créer un observatoire national des
violences spécifiques aux sapeurs
pompiers l'objectif essaie de mieux
prévenir les agressions dont vous êtes
de plus en plus victimes
sur ce point vous avez le sentiment que
c'est la reconnaissance des contraintes
et des risques particuliers qui sont
inhérents à votre métier c'est une
violence et une partie seulement des
était la réponse nous sommes une
profession reconnue comme dangereuse par
le code de sécurité intérieure et les
violences sont un sujet qu'il faut
prendre en compte la nobserverie voir
c'est bien il ya des petites mesures qui
sont mises en place qui sont testés il
faut vraiment une stratégie globale sur
le long terme parce que ça relève à la
fois de conditions matérielles de
condition d'effectif
et puis de conditions d'éducation de la
population mais pour nous le premier
point sera effectif suffisant pour
assurer notre propre sécurité en
intervention et sur ce point que vous a
répondu le ministre de l'intérieur sur
ce point la partie un peu plus compliqué
puisque nous dépendons à la fois du
ministre de l'intérieur de l'état mais
également des collectivités locales
puisque nous sommes des services
départementaux et de ce point de vue là
il faut travailler avec les financeurs
que sont les pneus les présidents de
conseils départementaux et les maires de
france aujourd'hui
combien représente la plupart de faim
comment est-ce que vous répartir y ait
en pourcentage vos interventions non
urgentes
elle représente et elles prennent
beaucoup de place oui dans la journée
des pompiers
et comment faire alors pour y remédier
alors les l'image des soldats du feu en
fait l'activité des sapeurs pompiers
c'est de délivrer des secours dont l'
incendie dont le secours à personne et
la part de secours d'urgence à personne
représente 84 % de notre activité dense
et 84% de secours à la personne une part
élevée constitue vraiment du secours
d'urgence pour lesquels les sapeurs
pompiers sont formés et interviennent
partout en tout temps en tout lieu et il
ya une part qui relève plus de
l'assistance à personne et cette part
qui grandit et qui vient un petit peu en
contradiction avec les missions des
sapeurs pompiers qui sont des missions
perçus comme étant des missions
d'urgence
donc il ya de plus en plus des missions
d'assistance et ça c'est quelque chose
qui vient gêner l'activité sapeurs
pompiers quand on part en interventions
ont porté secours 84% notre activité
mais il ya très peu de situations il ya
17 % des situations dans lesquelles on
se sent vraiment du matériel et on
intervient vraiment situations d'urgence
et qu'est ce que vous proposez vous pour
remédier à cette situation le travail
des sapeurs pompiers a toujours été de
répondre à la sollicitation des citoyens
ce soit pour l'instant 10 pour le
secours routier
la demande de la société a évolué on
demande maintenant de faire de
l'assistance à personne une secours à
personne il faut l'organiser
on a actuellement un système qui est
extrêmement performant dans l'urgence et
qui est prouvé il faut faire évoluer ce
système pour travailler sur l'assistance
à personne et peut-être répartir sur
d'autres acteurs et adapter notre propre
organisation
on peut pas aller faire de l'assistance
à personne avec des moyens de secours
d'urgence qui ne sont pas faits pour ça
on ne prend pas un marteau pour écraser
une mouche
ce sont les services de santé qui
doivent être davantage mobilisés au qui
sont dans la rue aussi alors ils sont
également dans la rue mais il ya qu un
seul service qui est capable
d'intervenir en extra hospitaliers
que ce soit en ruralité en tout le temps
en tout lieu
ce sont les sapeurs fonctionne d'avoir
maillage territorial qui nous permettra
de cette action nous sommes sollicités
parce que nous sommes le seul service en
capacité de répondre efficacement à
cette demande nous faisons avec une
augmentation d'activité de 6 à 7 % tous
les ans donc nous sommes capables de le
faire il faut simplement derrière des
moyens et une organisation un peu mieux
dans l'eau va revenir sur la
manifestation d'hier assez rapidement
mais vous votre syndicat n'a pas appelé
à mobiliser malgré tout comment n'a pas
appelé à ce que ses membres à manifester
pardon mais malgré tout comment est ce
que vous avez reçu ces images de
violence assez forte entre un pompier et
et forces de l'ordre
nous n'avions pas être bien manifester
puisque jusque ministre a annoncé hier
nous avions travaillé avec lui en amont
et nous nous connaissions ce qui allait
être annoncée donc nous étions c'est
déjà satisfait les images qui sont
donnés à voir son sont toujours
mauvaises ça soit pour la profession
pour la poêle à pour la société en
général
elles sont le reflet d'un petit groupe
les images parlent d'elles mêmes et on
voit un petit groupe de sapeurs pompiers
qui ne représente pas les 45000 sapeurs
pompiers professionnels de france
nous les dénonçons
il ya la force qui doit être du côté de
la force publique deux de la police et
les violences que l'on constate nous les
dénonçons merci beaucoup d'être venu
répondre à nos questions ce matin il le
cra je rappelle que vous êtes un vice
président du syndicat national des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels